title of the story, suddenly it becomes a
new word?
Coincidence, you may say now, BUT: When you
take the same D initial and put it in front
of Enies lobby that otherwise makes no fucking
sense, it suddenly becomes another English
word.
Denies.
Yeah, I know.
Blew my mind as well.
So now that I know you're gonna watch this
video till the end, let me tell you the crazy
story of how the Japanese one piece community
convinced me that the ancient kingdom was
part of Jaya, that it's now at the bottom
of the sea under enies lobby and that Skypea
and Dressrosa tell us what happened during
the void century.
At the end of this, I promise you you will
laugh as maniacally as I did when I found
out how in your face this all was all along.
No wonder that Roger laughed.
Here we go.
I'm so excited to share this.
In chapter 253 we learn that upper yard in
Skypea, actually used to be part of the island
Jaya down on sea level.
When you put both maps together, they form
a giant skull shaped island, with modern Jaya
being the teeth, and the legendary golden
city of shandora as the right eye.
Oh yeah, and there is a giant perfectly round
gaping hole, where the other eye is.
Why is no-one mentioning this.
There is an ancient city in the one eye and
the second eye looks like someone ripped out
the one piece of the island that made the
second eye of the skull.
Wait, one piece.
Are you telling me...
Yes!
This is also about the true nature of the
one piece and why Skypea was actually not
the least important, but THE most fucking
important arc in the story.
And we all didn't see it.
I stumbled across the center piece for this
theory, when doing research for my Enel video.
I came across this new Japanese one piece
Youtuber, called Yude Ron, who absolutely
rocks this draft punk mask here and who had
this crazy video about the true essence of
the one piece.
Since I luckily speak Japanese, I watched
it all and it blew my mind so damn hard I
think I just sat there for 5 minutes staring
at my pc.
For whatever reason this theory does just
not exist in the English speaking community,
so I asked him on twitter if he would be willing
to share his thought, and--got completely
ghosted.
He followed me back though.
Thanks [grin thumbs up]!
So, in good old pirate spirit I decided to
share with the people what belongs with the
people.
As a result, a big chunk of this video is
thanks to Yude Ron, but I of course also added
a lot of my own thoughts and ideas to this.
The first thing that absolutely caught me
by surprise, is how much more Oda seems to
play with words, numbers and letters than
we English speaking fans seem to realize.
Best example, that is also relevant for this
video, is one piece itself.
In Japanese One Piece, is written in the katakana
alphabet as Wanpiisu, but this is only on
top of an Japanese word:“hito-tsunagi daihiho”.
This usually is read as Hito Tsunagi, the
great treasure of the one piece, as in the
one piece of a whole.
Hito as in one.
However, this could also be read as Hito-tsunagi,
Hita as in humans, making it the treasure
that connects people, which of course one
piece is all about.
So, as I was saying, the core idea of this
theory, is that Jaya did not only lose a chunk
of its land once, when the upper yard was
catapulted into the sky by the knock up stream
400 years ago, but also 800 years ago, when
the city, located in the left eye was ripped
out in the war with the world government.
Which, when we look at the map, would theoretically
work right?
A city as the right eye and a city as the
left eye, making this island one ancient kingdom.
So what's my proof for this?
Oh, there is a lot.
First of all, the name of the series.
One Piece?
And there is exactly one piece missing in
this map?
If laugh tale itself was the one piece, missing
from the former ancient kingdom, That would
fit right?
No pun intended.
Then there is also a ton of small hints regarding
the left eye being hidden or destroyed.
In the cover of volume 27, Luffy has his left
eye closed, and I noticed that the same is
true for Robin in volume 24.
We also have Pedros missing left eye, shanks'
scary, luffy's scar, zoro's scar, and the
Jolly Roger of Doflamingo, a former celestial
dragon, where the skull's left eye is literally
stoked out.
At this point I was like, 'yeah okay that's
nice and all, but if that's all--, Oh, but
there is so much more.
We're just getting started here.
The volumes surrounding the Sykpea arc are
actually some of the most critical in the
entire story.
Tons of important characters get introduced
here.
We meet Blackbeard, and learn about the importance
of dreams.
We meet Bellamy and Doflamingo, who are also
extremely relevant to this Theory.
And we see the meetings of shanks and whitebeaerd
as well as ace and buggy, all of which are
closely connected to Roger, who by the way
decides to leave a little message on the poneglyph
in shandora out of all places.
But the person most connected to Roger in
a way, that we meet in this arc is Mont Blanc
Noland.
He is a direct parallel to Roger, and their
connection is a big hint that jaya was the
ancient kingdom and that laugh tale is the
missing part.
Think about it!
Noland is basically, over, but inverted.
Both of them were powerful free-spirited adventures.
This panel here, where only Nolan can hear
the voice of the bell, strongly suggest that
just like luffy and Roger, he had the voices
of all things.
Both of them found legendary places, shandora
and laugh tale.
Both came back with no evidence and Both were
sentenced to death and executed.
However, here the things start to invert each
other.
While Nolan was deemed a liar for his speech,
Roger sparked a new era of piracy.
Noland didn't know the way back to shandora,
but Roger did know the way to laugh tale.
Noland cried, while Roger laughed.
And Nolan told the truth, as the city of gold
was real, while Roger lied, as the core of
the one piece is not gold and silver.
Given all these parallels, wouldn't it make
a lot of sense that Nolan found the city of
the right eye, while Roger found the one of
the left?
In Mock town, at the beginning of the arc,
Bellamy makes fun of dreamers and says that
the era of dreams is over.
He explicitly names the golden city and the
one piece as two such delusions.
And yet, the arc ends with Luffy ringing the
golden bell, proving that the golden city
was there all along.
Well wouldn't it be extremely fitting, even
ironic, if the one piece, in other words,
the lost city, used to be in the very same
spot, that Bellamy used to make fun of both?
Further, Robin explicitly states that there
is no doubt that this city, Sandra, fought
against the enemy.
Well, if shandora was part of the kingdom,
that would only be logical then wouldn't it?
Not only as an ally, but as part of the whole.
Also, we can't ignore the fact, that SHandora,
is the only place we know of, where the ancient
script found on the poneglyphs is used as
the regular writing system found on the buildings
there.
Since we now know that the Kozuki clan were
the ones who created the poneglyphs for the
ancient kingdom, and that this script is used
very casually here, wouldn't the easiest explanation
be, that shandora was part of the ancient
kingdom?
Wouldn't that also explain why the sun god,
who we know know as Nika is heavily referenced
here by the people?
We even see luffy in the exact same pose as
him.
And doesn't Nika also remind you a bit of
the shandies soldiers?
And since both Nika and joy boy, names associated
with laughter, quite possibly describe the
very same person from 800 years ago, wouldn't
it make sense, that these traditions live
on Jaya when it was once one big kingdom?
Oh, I thought, but the sun isn't the only
majorly important symbol in the story.
One of the most consistently returning themes
in one piece is also the moon.
It's everywhere, and I can't even begin to
count all the significant things that have
happened under a full moon in the story.
The Sun and the moon, obviously go hand in
hand in pretty much any mythology.
On Zou, another ally of the ancient kingdom,
we even have guardians of the night and day
with nekomamushi and inuarashi.
So wouldn't it make sense for the right city
to be the city of the sun and the left the
city of the moon?
Which by the way is part of the Kozuki heritage,
and whose crest is pretty much the same as
the shandians.
And while I was thinking this, I found this
color spread of chapter 269, where we see
the Straw hats in a place looking suspicious
like Wano, surrounded by the birds from the
Kozuki crest.
Oh and by the way, the Kozuki crest also has
cross bones, but no skull.
This is 269.
The last panel of chapter 268 is this.
Yeah.
Coincidence?
The inscription on the pillar that robin reads
in the ruins says: We are the ones who weave
history with the reverberations of the great
bell.
C'mon.
We are the ones wbo Weave history?
Clearly the Kozuki.
And it also reminds me of the verse from binks
sake that says: Sayonara minato, Tsumugi no
sato yo.
Goodbye harbor of the spinning village.
On top of that I then remembered, that the
shandians came down from the moon to jaya
with very advanced technology, making them
the perfect candidates to be part of an ancient
powerful kingdom.
Okay, I'm gonna let you breath a moment here.
- [Drinks]
Okay, break over.
Next up, is a part that I completely got from
Yuderon, that changed my perspective on Oda's
writing completely.
According to him, Oda absolutely loves playing
with the numbers of the chapters to either
describe what happens in the chapter or hide
a message.
One really interesting and way to specific
date that Oda gives us in the story is the
12th of MAY 1122, the day Noland discovers
Jaya.
Oda never gives us dates for anything, so
why now.
The date in japanese is written as, year,
month ,day, so 1122, 5 , 12.
Now, if you take the individual numbers and
their pronunciation from both Japanese and
English you get this.
Hi to tsu ni ko ko ni iru.
One is here.
Interestingly the volume title of 31, is also
kokoniiru.
I am right here.
Is this the one piece literally telling us
it's right here?
The next date we get is the 16th of November
1127, when sahndora gets knocked into the
sky.
Same game.
This time we get: Hitotsunagi ininto rodoroku.
Do you remember?
Hitotsunagi, is the one piece.
And inin is the sound of a bell.
Thus this date reads: The one piece roars
with the reverberation of a bell.
The bell coincidentally being part of the
unfulfilled promised to Noland to ring the
bell, that was then inherited over generations
until luffy fulfilled it.
Another promise that was unfulfilled and inherited
to future generations was that of joy boy
800 years ago.
So when you subtract another 400 years back
to the void century from Nolan's two dates
400 years ago, 1122 and 1127 minus 400, you
get the years 722 and 727.
The first possibly marking the promise by
joy boy to the princess and the second the
year of the destruction of the ancient kingdom.
I know we'Re really deep into this all right
now, but stay with me, because what came next
blew my mind.
When you take these two numbers 722 and 727
and look at the corresponding chapters, you
don't get some random stuff happening.
No. 722 is the reveal that Doflamingo is a
celestial dragon.
In this chapter, he tells law about how the
twenty kings created the World Government.
Nineteen of the twenty families decided to
move to Mary Geoise, the Nefertari family
being the only one who did not go.
The descendants of the kings, the World Nobles,
still live there today.
This meant nineteen countries had to elect
new royalty and new families were established.
He says that the new ruling family in Dressrosa
was the Riku Family, while the family that
left for Mary Geoise was the Donquixote Family.
Anything else that might be interesting happening
in this chapter?
Oh yeah, we have a literal golden bell ringing
in closeup.
You think that was all?
Huh.
Remember Giolla and her great art skills?
Yeah me neither, but look at this abstract
master piece of hers.
A giant gate with two eyes, the left, bright
like the sun is open, the other dark like
the night is crying.
I think I don't have to spell this one out
for you right?
This might well represent the ancient kingdom
being destroyed and ripped out of jaya.
All while brook is playing music on top of
it.
And after defeating Giolla he even says this:
- Meanwhile, the straw hats and tontata start
the battle to restore the honor of the fallen
king and remain their freedom.
Chapter 727 meanwhile, where the fight in
block D!!
Continues.
Hemhem, we hear the story of Doflamingo taking
over the country by staging king Riku and
his men going against their own people.
The wordplay for this chapter number is chi
ni ochiru.
Falling to the ground.
Not only how dressrosa fell, but also how
the ancient kingdom fell?
giolla even says that her cryptic art represents
the tragedy of dressroas.
So also the tragedy of the ancient kingdom?
Now, you might say, if Dressrosa is a representation
of the fall of the ancient kingdom, what connection
is there between, shandora and dressrosa?
- Oh right, this is rhetorical question.
The connection is this: - [Noland Statue]
The chapter where noalnd find out that shandora
has vanished, while Kalgara waits for Nolands
promised return is chapter 292, titled 'like
the half moon hidden by the clouds'.
Again the symbol of the moon, that we can
also find on Nolands ship in the chapter.
And the wordplay for this one is tsuki ni,
two moons.
In other words, two half moons making a whole?
Making it the sun?
Wouldnt it also make a lot of sense that the
D is actually a half moon?
800 years ago the people of the sun were overthrown
and the done piece became the one piece.
A circle became half a circle and eventually
a letter.
The will of D then, being to be made one whole
again?
Becoming the sun?
Okay, I thought to myself at this point, this
already makes way to much sense.
But now on to the biggest mystery of it all:
Why do I think that the one piece and or laugh
tale is at Enies Lobby?
That Enies Lobby by the way, who's main villain
is called Rob Lucci, the one who steals the
light.
Just saying.
So, we have one piece, that when adding the
D to it gives us a done piece.
The first thing that connects enies lobby
to this, is that it also takes a d.
Huh.
Suddenly Enies becomes Denies.
Denies what?
It's probably more of a who.
Enies Lobby is one of the most freakish places
we have ever visited.
It
is one of the central government facilities,
but it makes no sense that they would hold
their mock trials on an extra island instead
of at impel down.
It never gets dark there.
We have the enormous gate of justice, that
no-one ever seems to bother to explain.
Oh and what the fuck is with the giant hole
in the middle of the ocean?
The moment I looked at ENies Lobby's Map,
it just made a lot of sense that this might
have been the missing piece in the jaya map,
that we are looking for.
Shape wise it absolutely fits.
I also wondered, if these weird ancient structures
on top of the island had any meaning, but
it doesn't seem like they do.
Could it be that this is the actual ancient
kingdom?
The missing link that we were looking for?
And the government just built it's own stuff
o the island?
Is that why they parade all pirates they capture
over this island?
As a forgotten tradition to remember their
victory over the pirate kingdom they fought
against?
It's called the island of justice after all.
Shihou no Shima in Japanese.
And here I'm a little proud of myself, because
I wondered that if there were multiple meaning
to the word for one piece, there might be
more to this as well.
Here is what the dictionary told me: Shihou,
obviously with different kanji combinations,
can also mean: 1.
4 directions, 2.
Secret information and 3 greatest treasure.
[Rubs face and eyes] So we have the island
of 4 directions, just like the 4 road poneglyphs
you need to find laugh tale.
The island of secret information, just as
the true history located on Laugh tale.
And finally the island of the greatest treasure,
the one piece itself.
Thus, the government has made this one of
the most guarded places in the world, where
no one can sneak in during darkness, no-one
can escape from without opening the gates
of justice and that is directly connected
to impel down and marijoe itself.
Entering the island for Luffy means declaring
war on the world government itself.
It's an island that D-enies entrance to the
D, the sworn enemies of the gods.
And since enies lobby is the arc directly
after skypea, wouldn't it be a classic Oda
move for the missing piece to be right there.
And the straw hats literally come to save
the one person that can figure out the true
nature of this place.
It's all about Robin and her unique ability
to read the ancient script and her search
for the truth.
And how the government is covering it all
up.
Hell, don't forget it's here that we first
learn about the ancient kingdom itself.
However, clearly the one piece is not in a
town full of marines.
So where is it?
Only one way to go.
Down.
Remember the inverted stories of Roger and
Noland?
Nolands city of dreams was pushed into the
sky.
Well, what if Rogers island got dropped to
the bottom of the sea?
Is there any indication that something might
be at the bottom of pennies lobby?
- WHAT?
The wordplay from chapter 727 was falling
to the ground.
Did Laugh tale literally fall to the ground?
I believe so.
I believe that Enies lobby itself is the missing
city from jaya and that under the floating
island is the island of laugh tale and the
one piece.
Just like the hidden world under dressrosa.
No wonder that Roger laughed when he reached
laugh tale.
He had literally been to the ancient kingdom
before and passed by laugh tale many times,
right in front of everyones noses.
And the ultimate piece of proof I have for
this are Rogers last words at his execution.
- Again the secret lies in the Japanese version.
A word play in true Oda fashion.
He says 'kono you no subete wo soko ni oite
kita'.
I left everything in this world Soko.
Soko in Japanese meaning there.
However it also has a second meaning.
Soko means bottom.
In other words,The second meaning of rogers
last words is: I left everything in this world
at the bottom.